the cordyceps fungal infection spreads
through direct contact with an infected
via a bite or indirectly via Airborne
fungal spores released by a corpse
Runners are individuals who recently
came into contact with the cordyceps
infection they're defined by their
intense speed sluggish attacks and a
tendency to attack people in hordes
stalkers are creatures who have been
infected from somewhere between two
weeks to a year per their name they
stalk and hide from prey in the dark and
attack at opportune moments clickers are
creatures that have been infected for at
least one year by this point the skull
has been completely split open due to
Advanced fungal growth on the brain
bloaters have been infected for more
than two years the fungus has led them
to become slow and blind yet incredibly
strong and resilient with the fungal
growth serving as armor plating
shamblers are creatures that have been
infected for even longer than bloaters
and typically inhabit areas thriving
with water the Rat King is a unique
stage of infected that developed in a
Seattle hospital after over 20 years of
infection formed from several infected
combining into one the Rat King is
colossal in strength and size